foreign
ly tracked down and was reunited with
her daughter Nastia after months of
separation
she traveled thousands of miles through
Russia to Crimea to rescue her daughter
says she was effectively tricked into
letting her go on a trip organized by
the authorities
is
soil
[Music]
swimming intelligence
like thousands of children Nastia joined
what was described as a summer camp but
she says it wasn't that at all
this is
when Russia paraded a group of Ukrainian
children on a Moscow stage with a
soldier claiming that they were saved
from Ukraine it caused outrage here
Ukraine has been telling the world that
its children were effectively being
kidnapped by Russia to turn them against
their mother country the ICC appears to
agree
president zielinski has been calling for
Action from the ICC since the start of
the year and doubtless he'll be pleased
as will his government about these
latest developments but it's probably
fair to say it'll not make much
difference in the short term that means
that many Ukrainian children will remain
in Russian territory
yeah yeah yeah because say if Ukraine is
an NGO that's dedicated itself to
helping families get their children back
they say Russia had a detailed strategy
and plan to take the children
they thought this through for I don't
know maybe for not even
um
for us who we must look at this from the
perspective of History
so it's nothing new
and this was this whole thing was
prepared and what do they do with
children it's like a part of bigger
policy that's all against Ukraine and
that's been thought about as a proper
plan yeah yeah we stand that it was not
only about
full-scale invasion in 2022 yeah it was
prepared long before this
the exact number of children who have
left Ukraine and may never be seen here
again isn't known
but the ICC moves May one day at least
bring someone responsible to Justice
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine